[Música]
voy a comenzar a contarles esta historia
que es mía de unos amigos y todo
comienza así hace tiempo estuve
relacionada con una persona que era
adicta era mi pareja
obviamente era una persona que tenía
muchos problemas de adicción y todo
surgió por tratar de
mitigar las penas y los dolores que a
veces nos causan la misma familia los
vínculos
obviamente yo como una persona que le
tenía precio que tenía un vínculo con él
no me daba cuenta de todo el daño que
nos estábamos haciendo juntos él con su
adicción yo con mi codependencia y con
mi necesidad de querer ayudarlo
no era solamente a él era todo el grupo
con el que estábamos otros amigos
yo misma con los problemas del alcohol
al principio todo parecía normal
salíamos de fiesta nos divertíamos
habían risas
todo funcionaba y
un día todo empezó a tener consecuencias
muchos de mis amigos dejaron la escuela
otros comenzaron a tener problemas al
deterioro mental
como lo puedo decir porque a veces en
las charlas olvidaban de que estaban
hablando se quedaron en blanco
comenzó a surgir la necesidad por
empezar a consumir más cosas conocíamos
más drogas más fiestas y ahí fue cuando
me di cuenta que cada droga tiene un
efecto distinto una duración distinta y
también ellos me contaban sus
experiencias
yo desde el espectador que siempre
estaba cerca me daba cuenta que también
tenían secuelas a diferente nivel
y todo aún así seguía funcionando
creíamos que no pasaba nada que éramos
jóvenes que estábamos chavos que
podíamos dejar todo esto en el momento
en el que quisiéramos sin ningún
problema
pues no lamentablemente no pasó muchos
de mis amigos dejaron la escuela otros
comenzaron a robar algunos murieron y
otros tantos pues fueron al reclusorio
es complejo entender cómo sucede la
adicción
y en algunos momentos me ponía a
preguntarme por qué estamos sumergido en
esto porque todos estamos juntos y con
el tiempo fui comprendiendo que todos
teníamos carencias carencias que
queríamos olvidar lo que queríamos
llenar
o que simplemente no queríamos afrontar
a veces no nos damos cuenta que el
núcleo familiar es donde inicia todo
esto
si en la familia es recurrente que
exista alguien con problemas de alcohol
que alguien se droga que exista
violencia que no te enseñen a sentir
cariño ni a darlo tú lo vas a ir
replicando no vas a terminar con esto no
hasta que te vuelves consciente de que
no quiere seguir viviendo así
como sucede esto como te das cuenta de
que no quiere seguir así que no quiere
sufrir que no quiere seguir te drogando
que no quiere seguir que alcoholizado
que no quieres llegar al día siguiente y
pensar porque lo hice porque me siento
tan mal
todo surge en el momento
en el que empiezas a quererte y a verte
en el espejo de todas las demás personas
que te rodean de todos esos amigos que
justamente se quedaron en la calle
de tu pareja que justamente ocupa cierta
violencia hacia ti y lo justifica con él
estoy drogado
estoy alcoholizado pero no quería
hacerlo o cuando tú mismo te justifiques
de tus acciones por decir es que estoy
triste es que nadie me entiende
cuando decidí regresar a la escuela y
estudiar filosofía
comencé a utilizar muchas de las teorías
aprendidas y no solo como teóricas
siendo prácticas ahí mi vida cambió
porque entendí que son luchas que no se
ganan para siempre se ganan día a día un
adicto siempre va a ser un adicto pero
tiene en sus manos la decisión de decir
hoy voy a estar consciente de que no
quiero recaer
un alcohólico igual
van a haber días que tengan ganas de
tomar alcoholizarse de perder toda la
noción de sí pero también puedes ganarle
a eso
usando el aparato crítico usando la
reflexión sabiendo quién eres quién
quiere ser y cuánto quieres que perdure
esto
las familias
los amigos nosotros mismos permitimos
que nos hagan daño y nosotros mismos
decidimos cuánto tiempo vamos a aguantar
este daño
ahora yo te pregunto cuánto tiempo vas a
permitir que alguien te siga haciendo
daño
cuánto tiempo más vas a estar sufriendo
por cosas de una familia que no dependen
realmente de ti cuánto tiempo más te vas
a estar aguantando esa falta de cariño y
justificando que como a ti no te diera
un cariño tu no sabes dar cariño
cuánto tiempo más vas a seguir
aguantando la agonía la tristeza
y no vas a querer hacer nada
desde el punto de la filosofía
está muy claro que puedes cambiar puedes
cuestionar te puedes preguntarte y te
vas a preguntar cosas que te van a doler
sí
pero también vas a querer darle un giro
de esto se trata la filosofía trata de
ampliar el pensamiento de cuestionarte
de hacer cambios de crear un ciudadano
un individuo feliz conforme con lo que
está haciendo para después poder
compartirlo para después poder decirle
al amigo
a mí me funcionó te cuento quizá te
funcione leí esto lo apliqué mi vida
cambió para esto
el pensamiento crítico
el cuestionar el hacer todo esto de
manera intencional
crea dolor pero también sana estoy
tomando la filosofía quizá como un pilar
un pilar dentro de la educación pero
también dentro de la vida real
el hacernos preguntas como quién soy
es algo que no cualquiera lo toma y lo
hace conscientemente
o connor es una filósofa que también
tuvo problemas de adicción
y de alcoholismo ella menciona que
cuando empezó a utilizar la filosofía de
igual forma de manera práctica empezó a
liberarse y volvió a regresar a la
teoría del libre albedrío a sentirse un
poco más plena con lo que ella hizo y
comenzó a cuestionarse ella dice algo
bien bien bien importante
dice que la voluntad de nada sirve
tenerla si no quieres utilizarla es como
un botón que tenemos todos pero hasta
que tú decides presionarlo todo esto
funciona
justamente este es el problema con las
adicciones con la ayuda con la necesidad
de afrontarlo y de no recaer cuando tú
quieres la ayuda van a haber personas
que te la van a ofrecer
hay instituciones para mantenerte es
limpio tu familia tú mismo el problema
es cuando nos justificamos y decimos que
queremos cambiar y es un arrepentimiento
pequeño porque en menos de una semana
vamos a estar exactamente en el mismo
lugar o peor de donde empezamos
la filosofía
ocupada de una forma real ocupada de una
forma en donde realmente quieres darle
una utilidad
se expande y te hace cambiar si te hace
cambiar como sientes que tanto te duele
algo o que tanto deja de doler te y de
importarte
las adicciones si se pueden trabajar si
puedes dejar de ser un adicto si
realmente eso es lo que quieres si te
puedes reincorporar a la sociedad si
puedes volver a estudiar puedes tener
una profesión puedes tener una familia
puedes ser feliz si son las cosas que
realmente quieres pero sí no
de nada sirve que tu familia te lo
explique que existen instituciones que
hayan comerciales
porque todo depende del individuo para
luego completar nos como sociedad las
adicciones están relacionadas
directamente con problemas que aunque no
parezca están ahí como ellos puede ser
la deserción escolar problemas de
enfermedades psiquiátricas problemas de
enfermedades salud nivel salud problemas
de violencia violencia de género
y aunque esto no lo parezca todo tiene
relación así como la filosofía y las
adicciones parecieran no tener relación
las tienen
como lo sé
porque lo viví porque lo estoy
aprendiendo
porque el intento compartirlo el primer
consumo ocurre de los 16 a los 20 años
es preocupante y es alarmante por la
razón
de cómo va a afrontar el conocer las
drogas el entrar a las drogas porque hay
algo de lo que estoy bien segura y es
que la pequeña línea la delgada línea
entre ser un adicto
casual de vez en cuando a un adicto
frecuente es tan delgada que no te das
cuenta cuando se rompe
pues bien sin nada más que agregar puedo
invitarlos
a cuestionarnos que sabemos de las
adicciones que sabemos de la filosofía
que sabemos de nuestra propia calidad de
vida
que tanto queremos cambiar nuestro
entorno que tan normalizado si estamos a
decir es normal sufrir es normal
lastimarlos
y que tanto queremos igual cambiar
qué tanto nos gusta nuestro presente y
cómo queremos que sea nuestro futuro
para dónde queremos que vayan nuestros
hijos nuestros hermanos nosotros mismos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]